I was thinking this morning about the
individual stories we looked at of a
campaign promise made by Donald and the
campaign breaking of the promise in the
president-elect phase from Donald and we
talked anecdotally about the immediate
backtracking on the Affordable Care Act
for example and liking some of those
provisions and I started thinking to
myself this is really racking up to be
quite a list of campaign promises that
he has already backtracked or mitigated
in some way or moderated on so I thought
well let's look at the actual number
that we're dealing with here and indeed
in the nine days since the election of
Donald as president-elect of the United
States he has already backtracked to
some degree on eight campaign promises
these were not small promises these were
major promises that the trumpets or I'm
told I shouldn't use trumpeter because
it's offensive to classical musicians
and jazz musicians the trumpets voted
for Trump in great part because of these
promises look at this list that he has
already said or implied directly or
through his through his surrogates that
he is not going to be doing jailing
Hillary Clinton I mean this was
ridiculous to begin with it was a major
campaign discussion lock her up lock her
up at the debate I'm gonna put you in
jail
etc well it turns out when asked about
it after the election he hasn't thought
about it much and he has other
priorities so that one we can basically
cross it off the list
the Mexico wall we will build it and
they will pay well Trump advisor Newt
Gingrich now doubts whether it will be
pursued at all and if it is it will
likely be some fencing on some part of
the border that Mexico will absolutely
not pay for number three banning Muslims
well we now have maybe Muslim
registration although I doubt that will
happen and we'll talk about that later
but the Muslim ban is dead it was one of
the initial promises that many of the
trumpets really liked taxing China I'm
going to talk in the next few shows in
more detail about this but senior policy
Advisor Wilbur Ross has already
retreated on this saying Oh Trump's been
misquoted about the whole big big tax on
China
that's not actually what he ever said
and it's not what he intends well he was
pretty clear about it during the
campaign that one is not going to be
happening the Iran nuclear deal number
five you'll remember Trump said during
the campaign he would rip it up well
turns out that adviser Walid Phares said
he will review the agreement well hold
on a second
ripping it up to reviewing the agreement
that's a pretty big backtrack I would
say the other countries will pay for
their own defense line from his campaign
Trump appeared to be saying he could
just pull the u.s. out of backing of a
number of different alliances including
one involving South Korea if he didn't
feel that other countries were paying
enough for their defense in a recent
phone call with the South Korean
president office they said oh actually
no we spoke to Trump and he's going to
continue at defending South Korea under
the existing security alliance not a
major issue for a lot of Trumpets but
yet another campaign promise for Trump
number seven bringing back waterboarding
said during the campaign that he would
bring back waterboarding in spite of the
fact that the practice was made illegal
after being used during the george w
bush era
well it turns out that now that is off
the list as well now you know these
these are not these are sort of
generalities when he meant bring back
waterboarding what he meant was not
bring back waterboarding and then number
eight as i mentioned at the beginning of
the segment scrapping obamacare he said
it would be gone it's a disaster and
after meeting with president obama he
said he now likes many of the provisions
very much and will be keeping them not
on this list which weaken it it's not on
the list because it hasn't sort of yet
been been really spoken about more
officially but already the tax cuts that
Trump promised if they happen are going
to be smaller than what he promised
other than the fact that there is going
to be a tax increase for the ten percent
tax bracket that will go to 12 percent
what do you think about this pad I mean
these are positions he took Wow as I
almost knocked my mic over because this
is just so crazy these are positions he
took and people voted for him because of
these positions
it's like poof they're just gone now and
what was his whole resounding message on
the campaign trail that politicians are
all talk no action they make all these
promises and then when they get into
office they don't keep them he wanted to
drain the swamp in Washington and yet
his whole transition team is full of
career politicians and lobbyists the
lobbyists part I read that pens today
said let's get at least some of the
lobbyists off of the transition team but
there's still many left and I don't know
it's just all such a train wreck and all
of the promises are coming undone what
exactly is Trump going to do certainly
not what he promised the trumpet that he
would do if they even cared what his
policy proposals were and many didn't
many said I just like the idea of Trump
it wasn't ever about policy right it
seems like he defrauded his voters as if
they were students at Trump University
yeah very nice I like that fat good I
would jot that one down I want to I want
to use that one again for Chanel